Let's talk a little bit about the
doctrine of tawriya.
Another one of the famous lying
doctrines.
Uh now this one is a fun one.
I mean I know I know it's not fun, but
it's kind of amusing.
It just shows you the license that
Muslims, you know, feel they have when
it comes to lying. So the classic
definition, which I give often, about
tawriya
and how this form of lying works is like
this.
As long as the word, what I say, what I
what comes out of my mouth, as long as
it fit fits the meaning, even though
it's I mean something else, then it's
not a lie. Okay? So the classic example
is some someone asks me, "Hey, uh can I
borrow 20 bucks?" And I say, "I don't
have a penny in my pocket." Now, any
normal person will assume by "I don't
have a penny in my pocket" is my way of
saying "I don't have any money."
But I might have a $20 bill in my
pocket. I just literally don't have a
penny in my pocket that I know. So I did
not lie.
Think about that, okay? So according to
Islamic teaching, I didn't lie because I
just said the truth. I said, "I don't
have a penny in my pocket." I don't. I
didn't lie to you. It's not my problem
that you took it to mean that I don't
have any money.
All right. Now I'm going to give you a
lot There's so many examples from past
and present sheikhs, including very
uh authoritative ones. Now another
famous one that I see often,
and I have um clerics on record who say
this. They say when you meet a
during Christmas, if you're in the West,
and you meet Christians and well, you
know, Christians are celebrating
Christmas, you can actually say to them,
"I wish you the best."
That's nice. All right. But then he
makes he clarifies. He tells you, "But
by saying I wish you the best, you mean
in your mind the best is that you become
a Muslim." Okay? So I really wish the
best for you, all right?
Of course, the
the goofy Christian's going to think,
"Oh, he's you know, he's he's he's
celebrating Christmas with me. Oh, he's
a moderate."
But, um you know, so there it is. That's
what it means. Now,
so as usual, taqiyya goes back to
Muhammad, the perfect example for all
mankind.
Um okay, here's here's another uh Sheikh
Uthman al-Khamis. He says that Muhammad
often used taqiyya. Okay? And as I
already quoted you, because Muhammad is
recorded saying, and Uthman al-Khamis
mentions these these hadith which I
already mentioned, where Muhammad says,
quote, "Allah has commanded me to
equivocate among the people, inasmuch as
he has commanded me to establish
religious obligations."
And I also told you that Muhammad said,
quote, "I have been sent with
obfuscation."
And whoever lives his life in
dissimulation, or taqiyya, dies a
martyr, right? And all these, by the
way, I had translated from Sami
Mukaram's book, Taqiyya fil Islam. Like
I told you, it's a treasure trove
of uh information on this a little-known
doctrine, and on deception in in
general, okay? Now, here's a good one.
And this is from the book.
In a canonical hadith,
Muhammad said, "If any of you ever pass
gas
or soil yourself during prayers,
okay?
And therefore, you break wudu,
um you should hold your nose and leave."
Now, and this is in Sunan Abu Dawud. So,
what does that mean? Well, as the
clerics explain it, holding one's nose
and leaving implies smelling something
offensive, which is true.
Though most people will think it was
someone else who committed
the stench and the offense, okay? So,
this is to save face and you're
embarrassed, right? You flatulated, or
whatever you did or however they you
know, while you're bending and
prostrating.
And yeah, you need to go and clean
yourself.
So just hold your nose and say face. I
didn't do it. It's someone else and
leave. Okay? And no Yeah, you're holding
your nose cuz it stinks. But you didn't
say it was someone else. But that's how
people will register it.
There's your prophet.
Now,
here is Imam Ahmad bin Hanbal,
founder of one of Islam's four schools
of jurisprudence, the primary one that's
actually practiced in Saudi Arabia.
Once when he was conducting class,
someone came knocking and and this
person that was knocking was asking for
one of his students.
So, this great Imam, Ahmad ibn Hanbal,
from behind the door said, "He's not
here. What would he be doing here?"
And the man left. All the time,
ibn Hanbal was was holding his hand and
pointing at it and saying, "He's not
here. What would he be doing here?"
So, that's not a lie, you see? Because
he was saying he's not in my hand.
That's it's not his fault the guy can't
see it. But his words fit the meaning.
He's not here. What would he be doing
here? So, the man left. This is the
founder of one of the main schools of
Islamic law. That's how well respected
he is.
All right. Now, also Sufyan al-Thawri,
with another important early Islamic
thinker.
He was once brought before Caliph Mahdi
and the Caliph refused to let him leave,
all right, for whatever reason, until
until Thawri, Sufyan al-Thawri, swore he
would return.
Okay? Swore by Allah.
And then the Caliph said, "Fine, you can
go."
So, as he left, Thawri, he just
clandestinely left his sandals by the
door and then he left. And then 5-10
minutes later he came back, collected
his sandals, and left. And left for
good.
You see, he didn't lie. He said, "I'll
be back."
And he came back to get his sandals, and
then he left. And that's not a lie.
That's actually promoted in Islam
because it's so clever.
And I know this is starting to sound
like stuff coming out of,
you know, 1001 Arabian Nights, but let
me give you some more modern Muslim
authorities.
Okay. So, here's Sheikh Muhammad Hassan,
the famous cleric who says Islam forbids
Muslims from smiling to infidels except
when advantageous. And he did say that.
And Abdullah Al-Shaqir who justified it.
They both give this example of someone
knocking on your door, and you don't
want to see them. So, a relative answers
the door saying, "He's not here."
But by here, they mean the immediate
room, which is true since you will be
hiding in another room.
So, he didn't lie, your relative. Okay?
Cuz I here, he means here, and you're in
another room, right?
Likewise on the popular
website, which I used to frequent a lot,
IslamWeb,
okay, where Muslims ask questions and
basically get a fatwa, get an answer.
Um a girl, I read about it, posed her
moral dilemma, which was that her father
has continuously told her that whenever
the phone rings, uh she's to answer
saying, "He's not here." Her father,
okay?
And then the fatwa online solves the
problem. It says, "You're free to lie,
but when you say he's not here, you must
mean he's not in the same room or
directly in front of you."
Okay?
Um
And here's the thing, you know, a lot of
this may be amusing and funny and and
and a lot of people may say, "Okay, you
know, these are just justifying white
lies."
But if we go back, um
you know, here's another quote from
Sheikh Al-Munajjid. He says, "Tawriya is
permissible if if it is necessary or
serves a Sharia interest.
Okay, so we go back to the original
formulation.
Islam's a war with the infidel, this war
is deceit, and what's a Sharia interest?
Well, empowering Sharia over the
non-Muslim. Therefore, taqiyya is
completely um acceptable, and Muslims
again have a blank check to lie. Bring
back
the flame.
Bring back
the fire
and the righteous
name.